वन एंड फर्स्ट ऑफ ल वेरी गुड टू
ल तो सबसे पहले मुझे बताइए सबको मेरी आवाज
सुनाई दे रही है आई एम
ऑडिबल प्लीज जल्दी से बता दीजिए चैट में
ओके थैंक यू पलब एंड मान सिंह शर्मा वेरी
गुड
इवनिंग यस थैंक यू मान
सिंह या आई एम फाइन
मतलब नहीं आवाज सही है तो आप अपने डिवाइस
की आवाज को
बढ़ाइए या फिर आप ईयरफोन का यूज कीजिए
क्योंकि मेरी तरफ से आवाज पूरी
है नहीं क्वालिटी ठीक है क्वालिटी में
क्या इशू
है क्वालिटी इज गुड
तो आप लोग बताइए लास्ट
क्लास सबने रिवीजन कर लिया सबको पता चल
गया बूट प्रोसेस ऑफ विंडोज ऑपरेटिंग सिस्ट
सबको क्लियर है लास्ट क्लास
में ओके अच्छी बात है अगर तो यहां पर नया
स्टूडेंट कौन है जो आज पहली बार आ रहा है
ओके एम कुमार यर फर्स्ट सेशन एमडी साह यस
यर फर्स्ट
सेशन तो सबसे पहले एक काम कीजिए आप तो जो
हमारे जो भी जितने भी वीडियोस होती है
हमारे डिफ अकेडमी चैनल पर तो सबसे पहले आप
उसको सब्सक्राइब कीजिए बेल नोटिफिकेशन को
ऑन कीजिए देन उसके बाद जो
भी जो डिस्क्रिप्शन रहता है डिस्क्रिप्शन
में आपको चैनल का लिंक मिलेगा और उसको
जवाइन कर लीजिए सो दैट कि आपको जब भी कोई
नई अनाउंसमेंट हो जब भी आपकी नेक्स क्लास
कब होगी और कब नहीं होगी या कुछ भी फर्द
कोई भी अनाउंसमेंट होगी आपको हमेशा व चैनल
ग्रुप में बता दिया जाएगा तो सबसे पहले आप
वहां पर जवाइन कीजिए तो वहीं से आपको नई
अनाउंसमेंट और नई नई चीजों के बारे में
पता चलेगा
कि नेक्स्ट क्या होने वाला है
यस डेफिनेटली यू कैन कनेक्ट विद ट बिकॉज
दे आर टीचिंग अबाउट क्लाउड पन टेस्ट तो
क्योंकि आप सारी चीजें क्लाउड पर है देखिए
पन
टेस्टिंग हर एक चीज आपस में जुड़ी हुई है
आप लोग सोचिए कि अगर आप मोबाइल पन
टेस्टिंग करनी है तो आपको नॉर्मल वेब पन
टेस्टिंग भी आनी चाहिए अगर आप करना चाह
रहे हो तो क्योंकि देखिए अगर मुझे एक फुल
ऑफेंसिव पन टेस्ट करनी है तो मुझे नेटवर्क
की नॉलेज होनी चाहिए जिसमें उस नेटवर्क के
साथ क्याक हो सकता है जुड़ा हुआ आपके
लैपटॉप आपके क्लाउड हो सकता है कि जो जिस
टारगेट को आप टेस्ट कर रहे हो वो क्लाउड
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर हो या आपके मोबाइल्स भी
हो सकते हैं क् मोबाइल पर भी सेम चीज यूज
हो रही होती है ना तो अब वह चीजें एक साथ
कहीं ना कहीं तो जुड़ रही है किसी ना किसी
एपीआई के थ्रू किसी ना किसी टेक्नोलॉजी के
थ्रू तो आपस में कम्युनिकेट कर रही है ना
तो इसलिए सारी चीजें आपस में जुड़ी हुई है
नॉट ओनली कि ऐसा नहीं कि मैंने ओनली बस
वेब पन टेस्टिंग सीखा तो मैं बाकी जनरल
पेन टेस्टिंग नहीं सीखू या मैंने ओनली
विंडोज पन टेस्टिंग सीखा तो लिनक्स नहीं
सीखू नहीं आपको पन टेस्टिंग एक छोटा सा
आपको सुनने में शबद छोटा है बट इसके बहुत
सारे छोटे-छोटे सब सेक्शन है जो जिसके
बारे में आपको नॉलेज हो और आजकल तो क्लाउड
पटे डेफिनेटली आपको आने चाहिए एडी भी आपको
आनी चाहिए
यस नेटवर्क टेस्टिंग तो आपको आनी
चाहिए देर ओनली 15 स्टूडेंट्स
दो मिनट का और वेट करते हैं उसके बाद
देखते
हैं तो यार मैं बेस्ट बॉस एक तो आपका रि
नाम नहीं है तो आपने नाम चेंज लिया तो
आपको लगता कि मैं हैकर बन जाऊंगा तो ऐसा
तो होता नहीं है और आपको ए तक नहीं आता या
ए भी नहीं आता तो बात ऐसी है उसके लिए
आपको बहुत मेहनत करनी पड़ेगी सच यह है कि
आपको एक से दो साल ओनली अपने फंडामेंटल इन
चीजों पर देना पड़ेगा जहां पर ओनली जस्ट
यह चीजें मैं सिखा रहा हूं य बिगनर से
लेके एक इंटरमीडिएट तक है बट उसके लिए भी
आपके कुछ फंडामेंटल नॉलेज भी रिक्वायरमेंट
है जो आपको क्लियर करनी होगी और मुझे नहीं
पता आपका बैकग्राउंड क्या है कि आपने कहां
तक पढ़ाई की है और कहां तक पढ़ाई नहीं की
है अगर आप किसी नॉन टेक फीड से आए हो और
बीए या एनीथिंग एल्स ऐसे फीड से आप शिफ्ट
कर रहे हो तो आपको बहुत ज्यादा मेहनत करनी
पड़ेगी सच है पर कड़वा
है यस यू आर कंप्यूटर साइंस स्टूडेंट तो
दिस इज द परफेक्ट कोर्स फॉर यू
दिस इज परफेक्ट कोर्स फॉर यू आपको बताया
मैंने देर 31 वीडियोस आर ऑलरेडी आई
डिलीवर्ड तो आप इनसे सीखिए आपको बहुत कुछ
सीखने का मिलेगा ले उसके बाद मेरे साथ
चलते रहिए हमारे एडवांस कोर्स करते रहिए
और आपका वन डे यू विल बिकम गुड पेन टेस्टर
तो क्लास को स्टार्ट करते हैं फिर आज भी
बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग टॉपिक आपका और काफी
इंटरेस्टिंग रहेगा क्योंकि बूट प्रोसेस के
बाद मैं विंडोज को के बारे में ऐसी चीजें
बताऊंगा शायद आपको नहीं पता था और उसको
आपको सीखने में काफी इंटरेस्ट आएगा और जब
आप पन टेस्टिंग कर रहे होगे चाहे वो
ऑफेंसिव पैन टेस्टिंग करो चाहे आप ऑफेंसिव
पैन टेस्टिंग करो तो यह कंसेप्ट हमेशा
आपको काम आएंगे ओके तो शायद हम एक काम
करते हैं कि क्लास को स्टार्ट करते
हैं यस यस यस यस डे 31 से अगर किसी ने
फर्स्ट टाइम क्लास जवाइन की है तो वो कर
सकते हैं क्योंकि डे 31 से जो टॉपिक ही
चेंज हो गया है
तो बिल्कुल ही फंडामेंटल्स है और यह
फंडामेंटल तो आप आसानी से कवर कर सकते हो
और आसानी से लाइव क्लास के साथ जा सकते हो
बिकॉज टॉपिक ही अलग हैय पूरा विंडोज के
ऊपर है तो विंडोज का बिल्कुल एक ही वीडियो
हो गई
हमारी तो एक काम करते हैं अभी सेशन को
स्टार्ट करते हैं ज्यादा टाइम वेस्ट नहीं
करेंगे तो दे आर ओनली 22 या 24 स्टूडेंट्स
तो
मे बी इससे ज्यादा तो नहीं आएंगे मुझे पता
है क्योंकि आप लोगों को इंटरेस्ट नहीं है
सब चीजों
में तो एक काम करते हैं चलो मैं अपने सेशन
पर कंटिन्यू करता हूं देन गो बैक टू
यस तो जो मेरा आज का टॉपिक रहेगा हम
विंडोज के बारे में थोड़ा सा और डीप में
जाने वाले हैं तो सबसे पहले हम सीखेंगे कि
जो विंडोज काम कैसे करती है अब विंडोज काम
कैसे करती है यह सीखने के लिए हमें विंडोज
की हिस्ट्री पर जाना होगा ओके विंडोज की
हिस्ट्री पर जाना होगा तो विंडोज वर्क्स न
बेस्ड ऑन सीरीज ऑफ इवोल्यूशनरी प्रोसेसेस
एंड इट बिगन बैक इन 80
अभी आज जिस कंडीशन में आज जिस फेज में या
आज जितना सिक्योर या जितना कंपैटिबल
विंडोज ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम आपको देखने को मिल
रहा है तो यह ऐसे ही नहीं देखने को मिल
रहा आपको अब 2025 है और अभी जो विज 12 भी
आने वाला है लेकिन इतने फीचर्स और इतनी
सारी चीजें थोड़ी सिक्योर भी है तो फिर भी
इतनी सारी चीजें होने के बावजूद इतनी सारी
चीजें हैं तो यह कैसे हुई और कैसे हमारा
विंडोज ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम काम करता है यह
सारी चीजें जानने के लिए हमें इसकी जो
जितने भी स्टेप इसने इवोल्यूशन बैक इन 90
80 की बात करें 1980 से लेकर 2025 तक
जितने भी इवोल्यूशन हुए हैं विंडोज में
बड़े मेजर इवोल्यूशंस की बात करता हूं कि
जब ws1 थी 1985 में देन उसके बाद अभी ट
2025 ws1 भी आ जाएगा तो अभी तक जितने भी
इवोल्यूशंस हुए हैं तो जो भी मेजर्स
इवोल्यूशंस है तो उसने कहां-कहां पर मेजर
चेंजेज के जिसके अ जिसके बेस पर हमें क्या
है कि ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम की वर्किंग समझने
में हेल्प मिलेगी ओके क्योंकि देर आर लॉट
ऑफ इवोल्यूशंस इतने सारे लश हुए हैं उसके
बाद ही हम विंडोज को इतना बेहतर तरीके से
देख पा रहे क्योंकि विंडो आज भी सबसे
ज्यादा यूज किया जाने वाला ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम है फिर इसलिए क्योंकि इसका जो
ग्राफिकल यूज इंटरफेस है जो इसका वर्किंग
कल्चर है तो काफी गुड तो अब इसके बारे में
जानते हैं कि विंडोज ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम काम
कैसे करता है तो उसके लिए हमें क्या करना
पड़े इसकी हिस्ट्री जाननी होगी तो आई थिंक
कि सभी रेडी हो हिस्ट्री जानने के लिए ऑल
आर रेडी
ऑल आर रेडी स्टार्ट
करें आई वांट आंसर फ्रॉम ईच एंड
एवरीवन क्योंकि काफी इंटरेस्टिंग सेशन है
और आपको जो बेसिक फंडामेंटल जो बेसिक
बेसिक आपके जो डाउट रहे होंगे पहले या हो
सकता कि आपको इन फ्यूचर आते तो उसके बारे
में हम डिस्कस कर लेंगे उसके बारे में
आपको पता चल जाएगा और कभी भी आप जब विंडोज
प पेन टेस्ट करोगे या विंडोज के बारे में
कभी आपसे कोई पूछेगा तो यू मतलब बेखोफ होक
आप उसका जवाब दे सकते हो तो अभी हम सबसे
पहले चलते हैं कि प्रॉब्लम ऑफ अर्ली
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम वाज कि जो पहले जो
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम होता था 1980 में उसमें
क्या प्रॉब्लम थी वस कि इन अर्ली ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम दैट वी हैड अवेलेबल टू अस दे
शेयर्ड ऑल द सेम मेमोरी स्पेस मींस वन
एप्लीकेशन यू कुड रन एट ए टाइम नोट टू और
थ्री एप्लीकेशंस ओनली वन एप्लीकेशन
बेसिकली जब मैं बात करूं कि 1980 में जब
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम जो जिस भी प्रकार का जिस
भी टाइप का ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम अवेलेबल था
हमारे पास जो भी ऑप्शन था उसमें एक
प्रॉब्लम यह थी कि जो विंडोज जो ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम का कोड था या जो एप्लीकेशंस का कोड
था वह दोनों के दोनों क्या करते सेम
मेमोरी स्पेस में रन करते थे व अपना जो
मेमोरी स्पेस था उसको शेयर करते थे उनका
मेमोरी स्पेस एक ही होता था उस टाइम पर
होता क्या था कि आप आपके पास चैलेंज यही
था कि आप एक बार में एक ही एप्लीकेशन रन
कर सकते हो ना तो ना तो दो ना तीन ओनली वन
एप्लीकेशन यू कैन रन इट ओनली एक ही
एप्लीकेशन आप रन कर सकते थे दो दो या तीन
तो छोड़िए ओनली एक ही एप्लीकेशन रन कर
सकते थे अभी और ऊपर से क्या है कि जो
मेमोरी स्पेस था वो भी शेयर होता था सेम
मेमोरी स्पेस था बिकॉज एप्लीकेशंस एंड
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम्स वाज रनिंग इन द सेम
शेयर मेमोरी स्पेस इन दैट केस वन
एप्लीकेशन दैट यू आर ट्राइम टू रन अभी जब
एप्लीकेशंस और जो ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम्स है
दोनों के दोनों सेम मेमोरी स्पेस को क्या
कर रहे हैं शेयर कर रहे हैं उस केस में
जिस एप्लीकेशन को अगर आप ट्राई कर रहे हो
रन करने की और यदि वो एप्लीकेशन आपकी
प्रॉपर्ली कोडेड नहीं है उस एप्लीकेशन के
कोड में कुछ एरर्स है या उस एप्लीकेशन का
जो कोड है वह सही नहीं है सही से उसको कोड
नहीं किया गया तो उसकी वजह से क्या होता
था कि पूरा का पूरा ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम क्रैश
हो जाता था या जो ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम बनाया
गया है उसमें कोई भी एरर थी या उसके कोड
में कोई कमी थी तो उसकी वजह से भी पूरी की
पूरी एप्लीकेशंस क्रैश हो जाती थी बेसिकली
मेरे कहने का मतलब यह है कि जो एप्लीकेशन
थी जो भी एप्लीकेशन रन कर रही है और जो भी
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम रन कर रहा है उनके कोड
में कोई भी प्रॉब्लम थी या वे स्टेबल नहीं
थे अनस्टेबल थे तो उनके कारण क्या होता था
कि पूरा का पूरा जो ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम था वो
क्रैश कर जाता क्योंकि वो सेम मेमोरी
स्पेस को शेयर करते थे और दैट वाज वेरी
बैड सिचुएशन इन दोस स्टेज और उस समय यह
सबसे बुरी सिचुएशन थी 1980 की बात कर रहा
हूं मैं सबसे बड़ी प्रॉब्लम यही
थी दिस वाज नॉट जस्ट ट्रू फॉर
विंडोज दिस वाज ट्रुथ फॉर ऑल द ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम एक्सेप्ट फ्यू एक्सेप्शन वाज यूनिक
बेसिकली यह जो चीज मैं आपको बता रहा हूं
या जो मैं कहानी आपको बताने की कोशिश कर
रहा हूं यह ओनली विंडोज के केस में नहीं
थे बल्कि जितने भी ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम थे सभी
के केस में यही प्रॉब्लम थी एक्सेप्ट ओनली
यक्स यिक एक ऐसा ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम था उस
टाइम पर 1980 में भी जो काफ़ी स्टेबल था
काफ़ी रोबड था बट इट इज़ वेरी एक्सपेंसिव
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम वह बहुत महंगा ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम था बिकॉज़ दैट वाज सो एक्सपेंसिव
देन ओनली यूनिवर्सिटीज और लार्ज और
कॉरपोरेशन कुड यूज़ यूनिक्स उस समय पर 90
जेच की बात करें तो उसका इतना ज्यादा
महंगा होने के कारण जो बड़ी-बड़ी
यूनिवर्सिटीज थी या बहुत ज्यादा बड़ी
लार्ज ऑर्गेनाइजेशन या कॉरपोरेशन थ जो
इसको अफोर्ड कर सकती थी वही यूनिकस को यूज
कर पाती थी एक्सेप्ट यूनिस यूनिक्स ऑल
डीलिंग विद द सेम सेम डीलिंग दिस प्रॉब्लम
ऑफ शेड मेमोरी जितने भी ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
थे यूनिक्स को छोड़कर सारे के सारे इस
प्रॉब्लम से जूज रहे थे इस प्रॉब्लम को
फेस कर रहे थे अभी नेक्स्ट लशन की बात
करते हैं जब नेक्स्ट इवोल्यूशन आया अभी
बात करते हैं कि बट इन द नेक्स्ट लशन ऑफ
सिस्टम जो था आपका विंडोज 98 विंडोज 98 की
बात करते हैं दे डेवलप ए बेटर सेपरेशन इन
बिटवीन देम वो सक्सेसफुल वो उनको सफलता
हासिल हुई कि जो ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम का कोड
था जो एप्लीकेशन कोड था उसमें उन्होंने
सेपरेशन कर लिया सेपरेट कर दिया उन दोनों
को कैसे देखो दिस वाज ए बिग इंप्रूवमेंट
एंड दिस विल टेक 10 इयर्स टू गेट टू दिस
पॉइंट अभी जो सेपरेशन क्रिएट करने के लिए
उनको 10 साल लगेगे क्योंकि 90 जटी से
कहानी स्टार्ट हुई नेक्स्ट लशन विंडोज 98
आया उस उस टाइम तक 10 साल हो चुके थे
सिर्फ ये चीज के लिए कि जो एप्लीकेशंस है
और जो ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम कोड है जो पहले
शेयर मेमोरी स्पेस को यूज करते थे अभी वो
सेम मेमोर स्पेस यूज नहीं करेंगे वो
सेपरेट रन करेंगे ओके दे वर डेवलप्ड ए
बेटर वेज ऑफ आइसोलेटिंग द ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
फ्रॉम द एप्लीकेशन एनवायरमेंट ओके कि कहने
का मतलब क्या कि ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम अपने
एनवायरमेंट रन करेगा और एप्लीकेशंस अपने
एनवायरमेंट में रन करेंगी ऐसे हियर वी
डोंट वरी अबाउट एप्लीकेशंस क्रशिंग द वल
पीसी यहां पर हमें यह चिंता करने की जरूरत
नहीं कि अगर कोई भी अनस्टेबल एप्लीकेशंस
है तो वह पूरे के पूरे ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम को
क्रैश कर देगी इस प्रॉब्लम से हमें एक
सलूशन मिल गया था बट प्रॉब्लम यहां पर
दूसरी थी कि वन अनस्टेबल एप्लीकेशन क्रश द
ऑल अर एप्लीकेशन लेकिन प्रॉब्लम यहां पर
यह थी कि जो एप्लीकेशन थी वो बाकी जो
दूसरी एप्लीकेशन थी उनको क्रैश कर सकती थी
अभी ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम तो क्रैश नहीं हो रहा
था बट क्या था कि जितनी भी एप्लीकेशन
क्योंकि उनमें से फॉर एग्जांपल थ सिक्स और
सेवन याय सात एप्लीकेशन रनिंग है इनमें से
कोई भी एक एप्लीकेशन अनस्टेबल होगी तो इन
सातों की सातो एप्लीकेशन क्या कर देगी
क्रैश कर देती थी अब यह प्रॉब्लम तो थी और
एक्चुअली दिस वाज द बेटर देन प्रीवियस यह
क्या है कि जो प्रीवियस वर्जन था उससे तो
बेटर था बट इसके अलावा कोई चॉइस भी नहीं
थी हमारे पास हमारे पास जो चॉइस थी अकेली
यही चॉइस थी ओके तो यहां तक सबको क्लियर
है शायद सबको समझ में आ रहा होगा कहानी के
रूप में सबका इंटरेस्ट बन रहा हो या कोई
बोर हो रहा है यहां पर
बताइए अगर कोई बोर हो रहा है तो वो भी बता
दीजिए
मुझे किसी को बोरिंग लग रहा है
बोरिंग लग रहा है ओके अभी बात करते हैं हम
जो सबसे बड़ा इवोल्यूशन आया था वह
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट एक्सपी से आया था ओके जो
विंडोज 98 के बाद जो नेक्स्ट बिग
इवोल्यूशन था जो बड़े चेंजेज आए थे वह आए
थे माइक्रोसॉफ्ट एक्सपी से अभी यहां पर
क्या हुआ था देखो फ्रॉम हियर वी गट ए मोर
स्टेबल ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम यहां पर हमें सबसे
हमें एक स्टेबल ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम मिला था
दिस इज वेयर कांसेप्ट ऑफ प्रोसेस केम कि
अभी जो मोस्ट स्टेबल ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम कहां
से मिला हमें माइक्रोसॉफ्ट एक्सपी से और
यहां पर एक नया कांसेप्ट आया यहां पर एक
नया कांसेप्ट आया जिसका नाम था प्रोसेस हर
कोई उसको यूज करता कि प्रोसेस क्रिएट होगी
ये प्रोसेस वो प्रोसेस लेकिन जो पहला जो
प्रोसेस का कांसेप्ट आया था वो इस
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम से आया था इट इज क्रिटिकल
बट वी हैड काइंड ऑफ आइडिया हाउ टू मेक ए
स्टेबल ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
अभी यह क्रिटिकल था बट हमारे पास एक
आईडिया था कि हम एक स्टेबल ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम कैसे बना सकते हैं वन एप्लीकेशन
वुड नॉट क्रैश द ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम कोड एंड
अनदर एप्लीकेशन अभी जब ये प्रोसेस का
आईडिया आया अब इस टाइम इस आईडिया के आने
के बाद यहां पर एक एप्लीकेशन ना तो किसी
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के कोड को क्रैश कर रही
थी ना ही दूसरे एप्लीकेशन के कोड को क्रैश
कर पा रही थी तो दैट इज द स्टार्टिंग ऑफ
स्टेबल ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम एंड द आईडिया ऑफ
प्रोसेस कम फ्रॉम देयर तो माइक्रोसॉफ्ट
एक्सपी तो अभी प्रोसेस होती क्या है यह भी
मैं आपको समझाऊ तो सबसे पहले हम बात करते
हैं व्हाट इज प्रोसेस अब यह प्रोसेस है
क्या ए प्रोसेस इज ए वर्चुलाइज्ड कंटेनर
प्रोसेस एक वर्चुलाइज्ड कंटेनर है हियर वी
अलाउ द एप्लीकेशन टू रन इन दैट कंटेनर
जहां पर हमें परमिशन थी कि हम अपनी
एप्लीकेशंस को रन कर पाए प्रोसेस एक
वर्चुलाइज कंटेनर है जिसके अंदर हम अपनी
एप्लीकेशंस को रन कर सकते हैं लेकिन
एप्लीकेशंस को रन करने के लिए और इस
प्रोसेस के अंदर एप्लीकेशन रन करने के लिए
उसको कुछ चीजों की जरूरत थी वह कौन-कौन सी
थी मेमोरी सिक्योरिटी सिक्योरिटी का मतलब
व्हाट राइट्स डज इट हैव और व्हाट कैन इट
डू और व्हाट कांट डू इट मतलब अगर प्रोसेस
के अंदर एप्लीकेशन को रन करना है तो उसको
मेमोरी की जरूरत है दूसरा सिक्योरिटी की
जरूरत मतलब कि यह एप्लीकेशन क्या कर सकती
है क्या नहीं कर सकती क्या-क्या इसके
राइट्स हैं क्या-क्या इसके राइट्स नहीं है
उसके बाद थ्रेड्स थ्रेड्स भी चाहिए
प्रोसेस को रन करने के लिए प्रोसेस रन कर
जाएगी एप्लीकेशन को रन करने के लिए
थ्रेड्स क्या है हर एक एप्लीकेशंस का आज
के टाइमर हर्ट है अब सबसे मोस्ट
इंपॉर्टेंट आफ्टर थ्रेड्स जो सबसे मोस्ट
इंपोर्टेंट जो चीज थी जिसकी जरूरत थी
प्रोसेस को और एक स्टेबल ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
बनाने के लिए वो क्या था आईपीसी इंटर
प्रोसेस कम्युनिकेशन ओके तो ये चार चीजों
की जरूरत किसी भी एप्लीकेशन को रन करने के
लिए एक प्रोसेस के लिए एक मेमोरी
सिक्योरिटी थ्रेड्स और आईपीसी अभी आईपीसी
होता क्या है इट इज बाउड बाय रिजट सेट ऑफ
रूल्स यह क्या है कि कुछ बोल सकते हैं
बिल्कुल
फोर्स सॉलिड रूल से क्या है एक इसके अंदर
क्या कि रूल्स डिफाइन थे कि कौन सी
एप्लीकेशंस किसके साथ कम्युनिकेट कर सकती
है किसके साथ कम्युनिकेट नहीं कर सकती है
एक एप्लीकेशन को दूसरी एप्लीकेशन साथ
कम्युनिकेट करना तो कैसे कम्युनिकेट करेगी
तो इस तरीके के रूल डिफाइन थे आपके आईपीसी
के अंदर ओके सो इवन इफ इट मिसबिहेव्स इट
ओनली डैमेज योर अगर एप्लीकेशंस फिर भी
एप्लीकेशन को ऐसा लगता कि नहीं मैं अपना
एरर कोड है और मैं कुछ भी कर कर लूंगी तो
अगर वह अपना मिसबिहेव भी करती थी तो वो
ओनली खुद की एप्लीकेशन को डैमेज करती थी
बाकी अदर एप्लीकेशंस को डैमेज नहीं कर
पाती थी बिकॉज ऑफ
आईपीसी एंड
ऑल द ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम डू एगजैक्टली व्हाट
आई एम टॉकिंग अबाउट दे मेक सम स्लाइटली
मॉडिफिकेशन ऑन टू दिस बट फंडामेंटल
कांसेप्ट इज सेम बेसिकली अगर हम बात करें
सेम है तो अगर आपसे कोई पूछता है प्रोसेस
क्या है प्रोसेस एक वर्चुलाइज्ड कंटेनर है
उसके अंदर आपकी एप्लीकेशंस रन करती है
लेकिन प्रोसेस के अंदर एप्लीकेशन को रन
करने के लिए आपकी प्रोसेस को चार मेनली इन
चार चीजों की रिक्वायरमेंट होती है मेमोरी
सिक्योरिटी थ्रेड्स थ्रेड्स हर एक
एप्लीकेशन का हर्ट होता है क्योंकि यही है
वो एक्चुअल कोड जो रन करता है और आईपीसी
आईपीसी सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट है क्योंकि एक
एप्लीकेशंस को अगर कम्युनिकेट करना है
दूसरी एप्लीकेशन के साथ डाटा शेयर करना
कुछ भी करना है तो स का यूज करना ही करना
है और हम डेली बेसिस पर बहुत सारी आईपीसी
का यूज करते हैं एप्लीकेशन टू एप्लीकेशन
या वन पीसी टू अनदर पीसी तो यहां तक सबको
क्लियर है
एवरीवन गट क्लियर यहां तक सबको समझ में आ
रहा है देर ओनली 17 स्टूडेंट्स
क्या होगा आप लोगों
का आप लोग तो
क्या करोगे लाइफ
में क्योंकि फंडामेंटल्स आपको समझने नहीं
है ओके अभी नेक्स्ट चलते हैं हम कि अभी यह
आईपीसी क्या है इंटर प्रोसेस कम्युनिकेशन
मैंने बताया आईपीसी रूल्स है तो मतलब क्या
होता है आईपीसी अभी हम क्या करने वाले हैं
आईपीसी के बारे में पूरा डिटेल्स में
पढ़ने वाले हैं कि आईपीसी क्या होते हैं
और हम कैसे अपने डेली लाइफ में आईपीसी को
यूज करते ही करते हैं हम जो भी काम करते
हैं आईपीसी की हेल्प से ही कर पाते हैं तो
आज आईपीसी ही हो पाएगा ठीक है तो आईपीसी
क्या रूल्स दैट अलाउ वन एप्लीकेशन टू टॉक
टू अदर एप्लीकेशंस यह वो रूल्स है जो एक
एप्लीकेशन को अलाव करते हैं दूसरे
एप्लीकेशन के साथ कम्युनिकेट करने के लिए
आईपीसी हैव सम सेट रूल्स दैट अलाउ वन
एप्लीकेशन टू शेयर डाटा टू अनदर और टॉक टू
अनदर और टू कम्युनिकेट टू ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
मतलब आईपीसी के अंदर ही वो रूल्स डिफाइन
किए जाते हैं जिससे एक एप्लीकेशन दूसरी
एप्लीकेशन के साथ डाटा शेयर कर सकती है
दूसरी एप्लीकेशन के साथ कम्युनिकेट कर
सकती है या ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के साथ
कम्युनिकेट कर सकती है विद दी हेल्प ऑफ
आईपीसी फॉर एम फॉर एग्जांपल अगर मैं आपको
बात बताता हूं आपने बहुत बार देखा होगा
आजकल तो बहुत कम देख देखने को मिलता लेकिन
कुछ दो तीन साल पहले की बात करोगे तो आपको
नॉर्मली यह देखने को मिलता था कई बार और
अभी भी मिल जाता है वैसे व्हेन यू सी एन
एप्लीकेशन जब भी आप किसी एप्लीकेशन को
क्या करते हो रन करने की कोशिश करते तो
आपको एक एरर डायलॉग बॉक्स मिलता था जिसमें
क्या नॉट रेस्पॉन्डिंग एक नॉट
रेस्पॉन्डिंग करके कई बार आपने देखा हो
एप्लीकेशन आपने क्लिक किया और वहां पर आ
गया आपका नॉट रेस्पॉन्डिंग एक एरर आ गई
इसका मतलब क्या था कि जो ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
इज टॉकिंग टू अनदर प्रोसेस और प्रोसेस
टॉकिंग टू अनदर प्रोसेस एंड इट्स बीइंग
टोल्ड यू जस्ट वेट मतलब ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
किसी दूसरी प्रोसेस में बिजी है और जो एक
प्रोसेस है किसी दूसरी प्रोसेस के साथ
बिजी है वे फ्री नहीं है इसलिए इसका मतलब
था कि वेट कीजिए समझ में आ इसका मतलब क्या
था वेट कीजिए तो एवरीथिंग एक्सेप्ट द
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम रंस इन ए प्रोसेस
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम को छोड़कर हर एक चीज
प्रोसेस के अंदर रन करती है एप्लीकेशंस
ल्स रन इनटू प्रोसेसेस और सर्विसेस आल्सो
रन इन द प्रोसेस ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम को
छोड़कर चाहे वोह एप्लीकेशंस हो चाहे आपके
सर्विसेस हो सारी की सारी एक प्रोसेस के
अंदर रन करती हैं ओके आपके सर्विस को भी
प्रोसेस की रिक्वायरमेंट होती है या आपके
एप्लीकेशंस के जितने भी कोड्स है उनको भी
रन करने के लिए किसकी रिक्वायरमेंट होती
है प्रोसेस की तो अब आगे चलते हैं काफी
इंटरेस्ट बढ़ेगा आपका धीरे-धीरे
तो किसी कोई यहां पर क्वेश्चन है या हम
आगे
बढ़े आगे
बढ़े
ओके तो अभी
आईपीसी क्या है अभी आईपीसी के बारे में
थोड़ा सा बात करते हैं कि ओपन सॉफ्टवेयर
फाउंडेशन है जहां पर लिनेक्स जब मैं जब
बात कर रहा हूं उस समय की बात कर रहा हूं
जब फर्स्ट टाइम आईपीसी के बनाई गई थी कि
एक ओपन सॉफ्टवेयर फाउंडेशन है जहां पर नक्
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट या मैक ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम सभी
के जो टॉप बोल सकते
टॉप आप एक्सपर्ट बोल सकते हो सारे के सारे
एक्सपर्ट ने एक साथ एक मीटिंग बलाई और साथ
में बैठे एंड दे सेट अप ए सीरीज ऑफ
स्टैंडर्ड्स एंड रूल्स वेयर बाय इवन आई
राइट माय एप्लीकेशन
के साथ कम्युनिकेट करना है तो मैं कैसे
करूंगा या विज प्लेटफॉर्म की एप्लीकेशन को
कि ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम डिपेंडेंट होते और
उनके रूल्स पर डिपेंडेंट होते क्योंकि
जितनी आसानी से हम सारे काम कर पाते हैं
वह सारे काम इतने इजली हम नहीं कर पाते
क्योंकि अगर विंडोज है तो विंडोज पे ही
डिपेंडेंट रह जाते उसके रूल्स पे
डिपेंडेंट रह जाते हम
नहीं किए जाते उस समय इन कंप्यूटिंग इंटर
प्रोसेस कम्युनिकेशन इज ए सेट ऑफ रिजिंग
रूल्स फॉर एक्सचेंज ऑफ डाटा अमंग मल्टीपल
थ्रेड्स इन वन और मोर प्रोसेसेस सेम अ
भाषा है या सेम डेफिनेशन जो मैं बार-बार
आपको बता रहा हूं कि वो सेट ऑफ रूल्स हैं
जो एप्लीकेशंस को डिसाइड करने जो
एप्लीकेशंस के लिए डिसाइड करते हैं कि
एप्लीकेशन कैसे एक दूसरी एप्लीकेशन के साथ
कम्युनिकेट कर सकती है इवन चाहे वो सेम
पीसी में हो चाहे वो आउटसाइड पीसी हो है
वो नेटवर्क के ऊपर हो ओके
तो देन अभी कुछ कॉमन आईपीसी के बारे में
बात कर रहा हूं कुछ मोस्ट पॉपुलर आईपीसी
जो हमेशा आप यूज करते रहते हो मैं वैसे तो
बहुत सारी है यह जस्ट फोर टू फाइव आपको
एक्सप्लेन करने के लिए आपको समझाने के लिए
कि आईपीसी कैसे काम कर रही होती है आपकी
लाइफ में ओके तो देखिए क्लिपबोर्ड कोम
डाटा कॉपी डीडी फाइल मैपिंग मेल स्लट
आरपीसी और विंडोज सॉकेट कुछ का नाम आपने
सुना होगा यह सारी क्या है आईपीसी है अभी
आईपीसी कैसे काम कर रही होती हैं आपको
जस्ट मैं समझाने की कोशिश करता हूं तो
यहां तक सबसे पहले मुझे बताइए कि आईपीसी
होती क्या है और क्यों बनाएगी यहां तक
सबको क्लियर
है यहां तक सबको क्लियर
है क्योंकि मेरे दोस्त जितने भी यहां पर
स्टूडेंट्स आए हैं उनको सच में बहुत
बेनिफिट होने वाला है मैं प्रॉमिस करता
हूं कि जो भी इंफॉर्मेशन मैं अभी प्रोवाइड
कर रहा हूं और जो भी आने वाली क्लासेस में
फंडामेंटल्स में प्रोवाइड करूंगा विंडोज
के फंडामेंटल्स में पन टेस्टिंग कोर्स में
कभी कोई भी ऐसी फंडामेंटल नॉलेज आपको नहीं
देता और यह आपके लिए बहुत ज्यादा हेल्पफुल
है इवन आपके इंटरव्यू पर्पस या अगर मैं
बात करूं आपके पेन टेस्टिंग जर्नी में भी
बहुत इंपोर्टेंट है क्योंकि जब आप एक
एक्सपर्ट पेन टेस्टस बनोगे तो यह सारी
चीजें आपको जब पता रहेंगी
जैसे तो आप क्या कर सकते हो अपनी जो मेथड
है या आपकी जो पेन टेस्टिंग है उसको और भी
एडवांस लेके जा सकते हो क्योंकि आपके पास
थिंकिंग होगी आप सोच सकते होगे जब आपको यह
पता ही नहीं होगा विंडोज कैसे काम करती है
विंडोज ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम काम कैसे करता है
उसके अंदर क्या-क्या चीजें होती है और
डेली बेसिस पर मेरी विंडोज क्या-क्या कर
रही होती है जब आपको यह पता ही नहीं है तो
आप कैसे हैं एक विंडोज को पेन टेस्ट कर
सकते हो यह सबसे सवाल है कि आप बताइए कि
एक विंडोज को पेन टेस्ट कैसे कर सकते हो
जब आपको उसकी नॉलेज ही नहीं है या किसी
इंसान के बारे में आप जानते ही नहीं तो
उसको कैसे थ्रेट दोगे वही है
ना किसी कोई डाउट है
क्लियर है तो ओके सबसे पहले मैं आपको
दिखाता हूं कि क्लिपबोर्ड को आप हमेशा
कैसे यूज कर रहे होते हैं देखो क्लिपबोर्ड
कॉपी पेस्ट मैकेनिज्म समझ में आ रहा है
कंट्रोल सी और कंट्रोल v हमेशा आप यूज
करते हो वह भी एक आईपीसी के थ्रू ही हो
पाता है ओके द क्लिपबोर्ड इज ए शेयर्ड
मेमोरी एरिया वयर एप्लीकेशंस कैन स्टोर
एंड रिट्रीव डाटा इट अलाउ यूजर टू कॉपी
डाटा फ्रॉम वन एप्लीकेशन एंड पेस्ट इट
इनटू अनदर एप्लीकेशन
आप जब भी एक एप्लीकेशन से डाटा को कॉपी
करते हो और दूसरी एप्लीकेशन में आप डाटा
को पेस्ट करते हो तो वहां पर आप क्लिप
बोर्ड आईपीसी का यूज कर रहे होते हो और आप
हमेशा डेली बेसिस पर इवन हर जब भी आप पीसी
यूज करते हो हर मिनट में या हर सेकंड में
आप उसको यूज कर रहे होते हो लेकिन आपको
पता ही नहीं कि आप किस चीज का यूज कर रहे
हो आईपीसी को आप हमेशा यूज करो एवरी डे यू
आर यूजिंग इट एंड मोस्ट ऑफ द पीपल डोंट नो
दे आर यूजिंग आईपीसी ऑल द टाइम 99 पर
लोगों को नहीं पता कि वह हमेशा अपने पीसी
में आईपीसी को यूज करते रहते हैं फॉर
एग्जांपल कॉपिंग टेक्स्ट फ्रॉम नोटपैड टू
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट वड ओके क्लियर है यह हमेशा
यूज कर रहे होते हो किसी को पता था कि जब
आप कट कॉपी पेस्ट करते हो तो आप आईपीसी को
यूज कर रहे हो किसी को इस नॉलेज का पता था
एनी वन किसी को भी पता
था किसी को भी पता था इस चीज का जो मैं
आपको बता रहा
हूं मुझे 99 पर लोग नहीं जानते इवन दे आर
डूइंग बीटेक बट आल्सो दे डोंट नो खासकर
हां उनको पता होगा जो इस लेवल की
प्रोग्रामिंग करते होंगे जो इनका यूज कर
रहे होंगे वो कर रहे अगर आपको देखना है तो
देखिए फॉर एग्जांपल मेरे पास एक फाइल है
मैं अभी बात करूं
मैं एक मिनट
पसी फोल्डर एंड विन मेक
एक न्यू फोल्डर एक वे
माय इसमें कुछ है मेरे
पास नो एनीथिंग
एल्स एंड एंड एंड एंड
एंड एक माइक्रोसॉफ्ट वर्ड मैंने ओपन किया
ओके ये रहा अभी यहां पर मैं एकता हूं आप
क्लिप बोर्ड कहां पर देख सकते देखो अभी हम
पर कॉपी की यहां पर देखो मैं आपको क्लिक
करता हूं कुछ नहीं दिखाई दे रहा आपको
क्योंकि यहां पर देखो आप अभी मैं इसको
क्लियर कर देता हूं क्लियर किया मैंने फॉर
एग्जांपल अभी मेरे पास कुछ भी डाटा मैं
यहां से उठा रहा है मैं यहां से लिया कुछ
भी एनीथिंग एल्स मैंने अभी क्या किया
एंड फॉर एग्जांपल एंड एंड एंड एनीथिंग
एल्स
एंड व्हाट इज आईपीसी लिखा मैंने एंड और कट
कॉपी पेस्ट कर रहा हूं मैं देखिए यह रहा
जस्ट कंट्रोल सी किया एंड ये रहा और
कंट्रोल व कर दिया मैंने जस्ट सिंपली कॉपी
किया इस चीज को मैं देख सकता हूं क्लिप
बोर्ड में देखो क्लिप बोर्ड में यह अभी
अवेलेबल क्योंकि य एक मेंटेन करता है
आईपीसी देखिए ओके तो यह है आपका क्लिप
बोर्ड हमेशा आप यूज कर रहे होते हो डोंट
सेव ब जस्ट आपको एग्जांपल के लिए शो करना
चाहता था नथिंग मोर देन अभी कोम होता है
कोम आईपीसी क्या होती है ए कम ऑब्जेक्ट इज
ए सॉफ्टवेयर कंपोनेंट दैट एक्सपोज सर्टेन
फंक्शनल थ्रो इंटरफेस दैट अदर एप्लीकेशन
कैन यूज अनलाइक नॉर्मल ऑब्जेक्ट इन
ऑब्जेक्ट ऑ ओरिएंटेड प्रोग्राम अगर आपने
ऑब्जेक्ट ओरिएंटेड प्रोग्रामिंग की होगी
तो उसी की तरह ही है रियल वर्ल्ड एग्जांपल
मैं बताता हूं ऑटोमेटिंग
ने डिफाइन किया कि ओके मैं इसके साथ एक
नया एक्सेल शीट ओपन करके उसके अंदर डाटा
को राइट करना चाहता हूं तो वो कैसे पॉसिबल
है क्योंकि एकल एक प्रोसेस एकल एक प्रोसेस
के अंदर रन कर रही है प्रोसेस फुल्ली
आइसोलेटेड है क्योंकि कंटेनर है और वो
फुली आइसोलेटेड है जब वो फुल्ली आइसोलेटेड
है जब एक एप्लीकेशन दूसरी एप्लीकेशन को
डिस्टर्ब कर ही नहीं सकती फिर भी आपने
python's की हेल्प से वो किया कैसे
क्योंकि वहां पर एक कॉम कंपोनेंट ऑब्जेक्ट
मॉडल की एक आईपीसी थी उसकी आपने हेल्प ली
और उस आईपीसी एक इंटरफेस का काम किया
जिससे आप क्या कर पाए उस एप्लीकेशन के साथ
उस प्रोसेस के साथ कम्युनिकेट कर पाए और
एक नया एकल पेज या एक एकल शीट ओपन कर पाए
फॉर एग्जांपल यह देखिए एक कोड है यहां
पर विन
32c c डिस्पैच
excel.com ऑब्जेक्ट दैट गिव्स द स्क्रिप्ट
कंट्रोल ओवर
एक्सल यहां पर किया जैसे यह रहा एक्सल डट
एप्लीकेशन इसने अलाव कर दिया इस कॉम ने
अलाव कर दिया कि आप क्या कर सकते हो एक
और एक्सेल शीट क्रिएट कर सकते हो दिस इज द
डेमो एग्जांपल तो यह था बस आपको इसके बारे
में ज्यादा जानने की जरूरत नहीं है बट
आपको पता होना चाहिए कि आप डेली लाइफ में
हर समय आईपीसी का यूज कर रहे होते अपने
पीसी में और भी बताऊंगा मैं आपको देखिए
डाटा कॉपी यह तो आप डेफिनेटली करते हो
ड्रैग एंड डप पहले आप कंट्रोल सी और
कंट्रोल v यूज करते थे वो अभी भी यूज करते
हो लेकिन ड्रैग एंड ड्रॉप ज्यादा यूज कर
रहे हो ड्रैग एंड ड्रॉप इज एन इंटर
प्रोसेस कम्युनिकेशन मैकेनिज्म दैट अलाउ
यूजर टू ट्रांसफर डाटा बिटवीन एप्लीकेशंस
बाय सिंपली ड्रैगिंग एन आइटम फ्रॉम वन
एप्लीकेशन एंड ड्रॉपिंग इट एन टू अनदर अब
क्या करते हो आपने किसी को मेल करना है
फॉर एग्जांपल मेल में कोई डॉक्यूमेंट
भेजना है क्या करते हो आप वहां पर अटैच तो
ना करते हो सिंपली आप गए अपने अ फाइल
सिस्टम के अंदर और वहां से सिंपल
डॉक्यूमेंट में गए डॉक्यूमेंट में उसको
क्लिक किया और सीधा ड्रैग करते हुए ऐसे
कैसे सीधा आपने क्या कर दिया उस मेल के
अंदर पेस्ट कर दिया और वह फाइल उधर अपलोड
हो गई वह कैसे पॉसिबल हुआ वह पॉसिबल हुआ
बिकॉज़ ऑफ दिस डेटा कॉपी आईपीसी इंस्टेड
ऑफ यूजिंग द क्लिपबोर्ड ड्रैग एंड ड्रॉप
अलाउ रियल टाइम डायरेक्ट इंटरेक्शन बिटवीन
एप्लीकेशन जैसे आपने क्या किया एन इमेज
फ्रॉम फाइल एक्सप्लोरर इनटू फो शॉप
टेक्स्ट फ्रॉम में वेब ब्राउजर इनटू वर्ड
अभी-अभी आपके सामने मैंने किया था ड्रैग
एंड ड्रॉप यह कट कंट्रोल c कंट्रोल v के
इसको ड्रैग एंड ड्रॉप भी हम कर सकते हैं
एंड ड्रैगिंग ए ड्रॉपिंग फाइल्स इन टू विज
एप्लीकेशन दिस इज आल्सो यह भी आप डेली
बेसिस पे यूज़ करते हो यह भी एक आईपीसी है
नेक्स्ट आपको बताता हूं उसके बाद डायनेमिक
डाटा एक्सचेंज डीडीई डायनेमिक डाटा
एक्सचेंज इज एन इंटर प्रोसेस कम्युनिकेशन
मैकेनिज्म दैट इनेबल्स डेटा शेयरिंग
बिटवीन एप्लीकेशंस इन विंडोज एनवायरमेंट
बेसिकली क्या करता है इट अलाउ वन
एप्लीकेशन टू सेंड रियल टाइम डाटा टू अनदर
एप्लीकेशन इनेबलिंग देम टू कम्युनिकेट
डायनेमिक फॉर एग्जांपल अगर हम बात करें
यहां पर क्या इसको हमेशा आप यूज कर रहे
होते हो हमेशा आप इसको यूज कर नहीं अभी
यूज कम किया जा रहा है आई एम सॉरी फॉर दैट
क्योंकि डीडी जब कॉम नहीं था और आपका ओई
के इंट्रोड्यूस होने से पहले डीडीए का
बहुत यूज किया जाता था आपने एग्जांपल
बताता हूं कि आपने खास कर कि आपका तो मैं
कै एज अ स्टूडेंट आपको नहीं पता होगा बट
जो प्रोफेशनल्स है जिसने काम किया उनको
पता होगा कि जब भी हम क्या करते थे एक
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट एक्सल होती थी माइक्रोसॉफ्ट
एक्सेल में हम टेबल की फॉर्म में डाटा को
मेंटेन करते थे और वहां पर हम क्या करते
हैं अगर मैं वहां पर फाइनेंस की टेबल
मेंटेन कर रहा हूं तो हर बार मुझे वैल्यू
चेंज करनी होगी और उसके बेस को मैं क्या
करता था उसको लिंक करके रखता था
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट वर्ड के साथ और जब भी मैं
कोई भी वैल्यू चेंज करता था अपने
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट एक्सेल शीट में और उसके जिस
भी सेल में वैल्यू चेंज करता हूं उस सेल
की वैल्यू सेम टाइम जहां पर मुझे क्या
करना है प्रिंट चाहिए ना एक हम एक कोई भी
पेपर पर प्रिंट चाहिए तो वह हम वर्ड में
हमने उसका एक फॉर्मेट बना के रखा हुआ है
तो व वैल्यू डायरेक्टली वर्ड के अंदर वहां
पर अपडेट हो जाती थी ऑटोमेटिक तो किसकी
वजह से पॉसिबल है क्योंकि हर कोई हर किसी
ने उसको यूज़ किया है वह डीडी की वजह से
पॉसिबल है ओके वर्ड क्लाइंट सेंड ए डीडी
रिक्वेस्ट टू एकल सर्वर एकल सेंड द
रिक्वेस्ट डटा उसके बाद वर्ड रिसीव द डेटा
एंड अपडेट द डॉक्यूमेंट अकॉर्डिंग वही
किया कि मैंने एक्सेल में वैल्यू को अपडेट
किया और वो वर्ड में जाके भी एक साथ अपडेट
होगी बिकॉज ऑफ दिस डीडीई आईपीसी सबको समझ
में आ रहा है
एवरीवन सबको समझ में आ रहा है कि आप डेली
लाइफ में आईपीसी को यूज कर रहे और आपको
पता तक नहीं है दिस इज द लैक ऑफ
नॉलेज
क्योंकि यह आपके लिए बहुत जरूरी है
क्योंकि आपको पता ही नहीं मैं करके आ रहा
हूं क्योंकि आई वांट टू बिकम ए गुड पेन
टेस्टर आई वांट टू बिकम ए गुड साइबर
सिक्योरिटी एनालिस्ट या आई वांट टू बिकम ए
गुड कंप्यूटर इंजीनियर तो क्योंकि
डायरेक्टली और इनडायरेक्टली एनी एथिकल
हैकर या इवन ब्लैक हैट हैकर्स दे आर वेरी
गुड या दे आर वेरी डम गुड इन कंप्यूटर
इंजीनियरिंग देर डम गुड दे आर वेरी
फैमिलियर विद द दिस मशीन तो अब वो
फैमिलियर कैसे हो सकते हो जब आपको उसके
बारे में पता होगा तो वही चीज है
ये अभी आप आईपीसी मुझसे पूछ रहे हो केस
देव यादव आईपीसी सेट ऑफ रूल्स होते हैं जो
डिफाइन किए जाते हैं और अभी आपको उसके लिए
अभी आप लेट हो क्लास में लेट आए हो तो वो
उसके लिए आपको पीछे थोड़ा सा पीछे जाके
देखना पड़ेगा कि मैंने आईपीसी के बारे में
काफी एक्सप्लेन किया है ये सेट ऑफ रूल्स
होते हैं जो ये डिफाइन करते हैं कि एक
एप्लीकेशन दूसरे एप्लीकेशन के साथ कैसे
कम्युनिकेट करेगी एक एप्लीकेशन दूसरे
एप्लीकेशन के साथ साथ कैसे डाटा डाटा
ट्रांसफर या डाटा शेयर करेगी या ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम के साथ कैसे कम्युनिकेट करेगी इनके
रूल डिफाइन किए जाते हैं आईपीसी के अंदर
और दीज आर द एग्जांपल्स मैं आपको समझा रहा
हूं तो अभी हम बात कर रहे हैं नेक्स्ट
आईपीसी मेल स्लॉट यह हमारा जीमल वाला मेल
स्लॉट नहीं है मेल स्लॉट आर ए सिंपल फॉर्म
ऑफ इंटर प्रोसेस कम्युनिकेशन इन विंडोज
प्राइमर यूज्ड फॉर मैसेज पासिंग बिटवीन
प्रोसेसेस आइर ऑन द सेम मशीन और ओवर ए
नेटवर्क द कांसेप्ट ऑफ मेल स्लॉट इज
सिमिलर टू ट्रेडिशनल मेल सिस्टम वेयर वन
प्रोसेस सेंड्स ए मैसेज टू अ मेल स्लॉट
एंड अनदर प्रोसेस रीड फ्रॉम इट बेसिकली
हमारे मेल सिस्टम की तरह कि मैंने किसी को
क्या किया एक ईमेल टाइप किया और सिंपली
सेंड कर दिया तो उसके पास चली जाएगी अगर
मैं मल्टीपल को भी सेंड कर सकता हूं तो ये
सेम वही प्रोसेस है अगर मुझे क्या करना है
कि ब्रॉडकास्ट करना है एक मैसेज को सभी
प्रोसेस के बीच में ब्रॉडकास्ट करना है
उसके लिए मैं मेल स्लॉट आईपीसी का यूज
करूंगा और देखिए मेल स्लॉट्स आर नेम
कम्युनिकेशन चैनल्स दैट आर यूज टू सेंड
एंड रिसीव मैसेजेस दे अलाउ वन वे
कम्युनिकेशंस फ्रॉम सेंडर टू रिसीवर एंड
दे आर यूजफुल फॉर ब्रॉडकास्टिंग मैसेजेस
टू मल्टीपल क्लाइंट र सेंडिंग नोटिफिकेशंस
बेसिकली आप क्या कर सकते हो एक ब्रॉडकास्ट
का मैं अगर मैं सभी प्रोसेस को कोई
ब्रॉडकास्ट मैसेज ब्रॉडकास्ट करना चाहता
हूं तो मैं मेल स्लॉट की हेल्प से कर सकता
हूं कंसीडर नेटवर्क नोटिफिकेशन सिस्टम
वेयर ए सर्वर सेंट आउट नोटिफिकेशन टू
मल्टीपल क्लाइंट्स द सर्वर कैन क्रिएट ए
मेल स्लॉट एंड ईच क्लाइंट कैन ओपन द मेल
स्लॉट टू रीड इनकमिंग नोटिफिकेशन तो दे आर
एसेंशियली यूजफुल ब्रॉडकास्टिंग मैसेज टू
मल्टीपल रिसिपिएंट्स एंड इनेबलिंग
एसिंक्रोनस कम्युनिकेशन बेसिकली अगर
प्रोसेस के बीच में कोई मैसेज ब्रॉडकास्ट
करना है तो उसके लिए हम क्या करते हैं
सीधा सा मतलब है कि मेल स्लॉट आईपीसी का
यूज करते हैं है देन उसके बाद आपने आरपीसी
का नाम तो सुना ही होगा और आईआरपीसी तो हर
टाइम आप यूज करते हो आरपीसी हर टाइम आप
यूज करते हो अभी भी यूज कर रहे होगे ए
रिमोट प्रोसीजर कॉल इज ए वेरी इज ए वे ऑफ
ए सॉरी इज ए वे फॉर ए प्रोग्राम टू
रिक्वेस्ट ए सर्विस और फंक्शन फ्रॉम अनदर
प्रोग्राम सर्वर लोकेटेड ऑन ए डिफरेंट
कंप्यूटर और मशीन बेसिकली मेरे कहने का
मतलब है आरपीसी एक ऐसा प्रोग्राम है
जिसमें आप क्या कर सकते हो किसी एक फंक्शन
की या किसी एक ऐसी सर्विस की रिक्वेस्ट
करते हो या तो वह सेम कंप्यूटर में या सेम
मशीन में हो सकती है या किसी डिफरेंट
लोकेशन पर या डिफरेंट मशीन पे भी हो सकते
हैं उसी प्रकार से अगर कभी आपने लाइफ में
प्रोग्रामिंग की होगी जस्ट आप किसी भी
प्रोग्राम के अंदर एक फंक्शन कॉल करते हो
यह उसी की तरह ही है लेकिन इसमें अच्छी
चीज यह है द क्लाइंट डज नॉट नीड टू वरी
अबाउट हाउ द फंक्शन इज एग्जीक्यूटेड ऑन द
सर्वर क्लाइंट को इसकी कोई चिंता करने की
जरूरत नहीं है इसके लिए आरपीसी है इट
लुक्स लाइक ए नॉर्मल फंक्शन कॉल इवन दो इट
इज हैपनिंग रिमोट भले ही वो रिमोट कहीं से
भी हो रहा हो लेकिन बस आपको इतना समझना कि
यह ऐसे ही काम करता है जैसे किसी एक
प्रोग्राम में आप फंक्शन कॉल कर रहे हो
आरपीसी बिल्कुल एग्जैक्ट जैसे आपको जो
डाटा चाहिए जो सर्विस रिक्वेस्ट चाहिए वो
आपको लाके देता है फॉर एग्जांपल इमेजिन यू
हैव ए क्लाइंट वेदर एप वेदर एप्लीकेशन है
ट वांट्स टू आस्क सर
जैसे वेदर सर्विस वेदर सर्विस चाहिए फॉर
करंट टेंपरेचर कि आपके जो वेदर प है उसको
करंट टेंपरेचर की सर्विस चाहिए उसको करंट
टेंपरेचर जानना है तो विद आरपीसी द
क्लाइंट मेक ए कॉल टू द फंक्शन गेट करंट
टेंपरेचर ये एक एग्जांपल है ऑन द सर्वर एज
इफ इट वर ए लोकल फंक्शन कॉल बट सर्वर
एक्चुअली फैच द टेंपरेचर फ्रॉम ए वेदर
डेटाबेस और एपीआई एंड चेंट द रिजल्ट बैक
देखिए अब सर्वर ने कैसे भी च कि हो डाटा
चाहे वो आपके वेदर डेटा बेसिस है या एपीआई
के थ्रू किया हो लेकिन आपके लिए जस्ट ऐसे
ही था कि आपने एक फंक्शन कॉल किया और आपको
डाटा मिल गया ये किसकी वजह से पॉसिबल है
आरपीसी की वजह से पॉसिबल है जैसे कि आप
क्या करते हो एक बैंकिंग एप्लीकेशन है
बैंकिंग एप्लीकेशन में क्या करते हो आप
बैंकिंग सर्वर से अपना बैलेंस चेक करते हो
तो उसके लिए सिंपली आप आपने क्लिक किया एक
बटन पे चेक माय बैलेंस और आपका बैलेंस
स्क्रीन पर शो हो जाता है आपके लिए बस
इतना ही एक बटन क्लिक किया उसके अगेंस्ट
एक फंक्शन कॉल हुआ और वह सर्वर से बैलेंस
फैच होके आ गया अब सर्वर ने चाहे कुछ भी
किया हो बट आपके लिए तो आरपीसी की हे से
बहुत इजी काम था ट इज पॉसिबल ड्यू टू
आरपीसी
आईपीसी दिस इज वेरी इंपोर्टेंट हाउ एन
एप्लीकेशन ऑन ए नेटवर्क टॉक टू अनदर
प्रोसेस ऑन योर पीसी दैट इज द मेन फंक्शन
ऑफ द आरपीसी नेक्स्ट अगर मैं बात करता हूं
विंडोज
सॉकेट यह तो आप अभी भी यूज कर रहे हो इसके
बना तो एक एप्लीकेशन दूस एप्लीकेशन के साथ
कम्युनिकेट कर ही नहीं सकती खास कर की
नेटवर्क के अंदर चाहे वो लोकल नेटवर्क हो
चाहे वाइड एरिया नेटवर्क हो चाहे किसी भी
टाइप का वो नेटवर्क हो इसके बिना तो वो
कम्युनिकेट कर ही नहीं सकती ओके ये विंडोज
सॉकेट या नक् सॉकेट यह जब आप सॉकेट
प्रोग्रामिंग सीखते हो सॉकेट प्रोग्रामिंग
कभी की होगी पाइथन में तो डीसीएसपी में
पढ़ाया जाता है कि जब नेटवर्किंग का पार्ट
होता है वहां पर आपको सॉकेट प्रोग्रामिंग
सिखाई जाती है तो वहां प इस कांसेप्ट का
डेफिनेटली यूज किया जाता है
पाइथन के अंदर जब आप खुद का कोई भी टूल
क्रिएट करते हो तो विंडोज सॉकेट या विन
सॉक हम जिसको बोलते हैं इज अ टेक्निकल
टर्म यूज्ड फॉर द प्रोग्रामिंग इंटरफेस इन
विंडोज दैट अलाउ कंप्यूटर्स टू कम्युनिकेट
ओवर ए नेटवर्क जो हमें अलाव करती है कि एक
नेटवर्क के ऊपर कंप्यूटर्स कैसे
कम्युनिकेट करेंगी इट प्रोवाइड्स ए वे फॉर
प्रोग्राम्स टू सेंड एंड रिसीव डाटा ओवर द
इंटरनेट और ए लोकल नेटवर्क यूजिंग
प्रोटोकॉल्स लाइक टीसीपी आप जब भी आप सी
या यूडीपी की हेल्प से कोई भी डाटा सेंड
करते हो तो आप इन सॉकेट का डेफिनेटली यूज
करते हो जिस भी मशीन पर आप डाटा को सेंड
करते हो या जिस भी मशीन पर डाटा को रिसीव
करते हो यह काम कैसे करती है व्हेन टू
प्रोग्राम्स वन ऑन योर कंप्यूटर एंड वन ऑन
अनदर वांट टू कम्युनिकेट दे यूज सॉकेट वो
सॉकेट का यूज करते हैं सॉकेट जस्ट लाइक
सॉकेट जस्ट लाइक वर्चुअल डोर्स एक वर्चुअल
डोर की तरह ही है ट ओपन अप टू अलाउ डाटा
टू गो इन एंड आउट मतलब डेटा को अलाव भी
करता है आओ और डाटा को ले जाओ बस उसके बाद
उसको क्लोज कर दिया जाता है क्रिएटिंग ए
सॉकेट ए प्रोग्राम क्रिएट ए सॉकेट टू
स्टार्ट सेंडिंग और रिसीविंग डाटा पहले
सॉकेट के लिए एक सॉकेट क्रिएट की जाती है
डाटा को सेंड या रिसीव करने के लिए उसके
बाद उसके साथ कम्युनिकेशन किया जा उसके
साथ कनेक्ट किया जाता है इफ द प्रोग्राम
वांट्स टू टॉक टू अनदर प्रोग्राम ऑन ए
डिफरेंट पीसी इट कनेक्ट टू ए स्पेसिफिक
आईपी एड्रेस एंड पोर्ट
नंबर सबको समझ में आ गया जब भी आप क्या
करते हो किसी भी नेटवर्क के अंदर आईपी
एड्रेस और पोर्ट नंबर की हेल्प से सर्विस
रिक्वेस्ट करते हो तो उससे पहले सॉकेट
प्रोग्रामिंग हुई रहती है उनकी क्योंकि
आईपीओ पोर्ट तो बता दिया लेकिन उसके लिए
दरवाजा खुलना भी चाहिए ना और वो दरवाजा
किसकी हेल्प से खुलेगा सॉकेट की हेल्प से
तो सेंडिंग एंड रिसीविंग डाटा वनस द सॉकेट
इज कनेक्टेड द प्रोग्राम कैन सेंड एंड
रिसीव डाटा ओवर द नेटवर्क जब एक बार आपका
सॉकेट कनेक्शन एस्टेब्लिश हो जाएगा देन
उसके बाद क्या होता है आप डाटा को सेंड भी
कर सकते हो रिसीव भी कर सकते हो
डाउनलोडिंग ए फाइल या चैटिंग इन द मैसेंजर
पप जब उसके बाद आपका कम्युनिकेशन कंप्लीट
हो गया इस सॉकेट को क्लोज कर दिया जाता है
और कनेक्शन को एंड कर दिया जाता है दिस इज
द परफेक्ट एग्जांपल ऑफ विंडोज सॉकेट तो
यहां तक सबको क्लियर है समझ में आया कि
सॉकेट भी आप हमेशा और हर टाइम यूज करते हो
यहां तक सबको क्लियर
है बताइए देर ओनली स्टूडेंट्स थ्री
स्टूडेंट्स जो जिनका क्लियर है बाकी किसी
को क्लियर नहीं
है ओके
नेक्स्ट विंडो सॉकेट ही थी अभी मैं आपको
आईपीसी का एक और एग्जांपल बता देता हूं
उसके बाद शायद यस ओके तो आईपीसी डज नॉट
आईपीसी वर्क्स नॉट ओनली बिटवीन एन
एप्लीकेशन फॉर एग्जांपल माउस कर्सर रंस
फ्रॉम वर्ड टू पावर पॉइंट यह भी आईपीसी का
यूज करता है एंड इट्स कॉपिंग कंटेंट फ्रॉम
वर्ड टू पावर पॉइंट स्लाइड्स और
सिलेक्टिंग द कंटेंट फ्रॉम कम ब्राउजर टू
वर्ड डॉक्यूमेंट ऑल दैट फॉलो आईपीसी रूल्स
सभी सभी आईपीसी रूल को फॉलो करती है यहीं
तक सीमित नहीं है सेम रूल्स आर अप्लाइड
फ्रॉम एप्लीकेशन टू एप्लीकेशन सर्विस टू
एप्लीकेशन और प्रोसेस टू प्रोसेस आईपीसी
वर्क इवन अक्रॉस द नेटवर्क फॉर एग्जांपल
यह मेरी विज मशीन है मेरा कम ब्राउजर है
यह मेरा एक
एब्लिश करना है तो मुझे क्या करना होगा
मुझे आईपीसी का यूज करना होगा मैं आईपीसी
का रूल फॉलो करूंगा विद द हेल्प ऑफ आईपीसी
तभी मैं इसके साथ कम्युनिकेट कर पाऊंगा और
अपने डाटा को एक्सचेंज कर पाऊंगा तो ये भी
पॉसिबल आपका आईपीसी के थ्रू ही है हर एक
जगह हर टाइम आप क्या करते हो आईपीसी को
यूज करते ही करते हो आईपीसी इंटर प्रोसेस
कम्युनिकेशन ओके अभी मेरा सवाल यह है कि
आपको कैसे पता कि हाउ डू य नो वेयर द
आईपीसी रूल्स आर यह आईपीसी रूल कहां पर
होते हैं देखिए जब भी आप क्या करोगे आपका
कंप्यूटर मैनेजमेंट ओपन करोगे तो वहां पर
आपको आईपीसी देखने को मिल जाएंगे सबको पता
है या मैं आपको दिखाऊ कि कहां पर देखने को
मिलेंगे आपकी मशीन में भी सेम ऐसा ही आपको
देखने को
मिलेगा यहां पर ऐसे यहा आईपीसी यह क्या है
दज हैव ए स्पेशल सेट ऑफ कम्युनिकेशन
प्रोटोकॉल्स दैट आर सेटिंग ऑन योर
पीसी सिटिंग ऑन योर पीसी एंड यूज टू टॉक
टू द नेटवर्क यहां पर जो आईपीसी आपको
देखने को मिल रही है रिमोट आईपीसी यह आपकी
इंटरनेट पर एक एप्लीकेशन को दूसरी
एप्लीकेशन के साथ कम्युनिकेट करने में
हेल्प करती है यूजिंग दज रूल्स यू कैन टॉक
टू अक्रॉस ए नेटवर्क टू अनदर प्रोसेस और
यू कैन नॉट मॉडिफाई दज रूल्स बट
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट कैन डू दैट आप इन रूल्स को
मॉडिफाई नहीं कर सकते लेकिन माइक्रोसॉफ्ट
इन रूल्स को मॉडिफाई कर सकता है ओके तो
यहां तक आईपीसी सबको समझ में आई अगर आपको
भी देखना है तो आप एक काम कर सकते हो यहां
पर यह आइकन है राइट क्लिक आपको क्या करना
है उसके बाद कंप्यूटर मैनेजमेंट प जाना है
देन उसके बाद आपको क्या करना है गो टू योर
शेयर फोल्डर देन उसके बाद शेयर्स दीज आर द
आईपीसी ये वो सारी आईपीसी है वैसे आप इसके
साथ कुछ भी नहीं कर सकते ओनली
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट इसके साथ कुछ भी कर सकता है
बट यू कांट डू एनीथिंग समझ में आ गया तो
यहां तक सबका क्लियर है आईपीसी क्या होता
है यहां जो भी कुछ मैंने आपको बताया कि जो
कि मैंने हिस्ट्री के साथ स्टार्ट किया
विंडोज ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम की कि पहले 0 80
में क्या प्रॉब्लम होती थी उसके बाद जैसे
जैसे इवोल्यूशन हुआ अ उसके बाद क्या है कि
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम को स्टेबल किया गया एक
एप्लीकेशन दूसरी एप्लीकेशन को क्रैश नहीं
कर रही थी बिकॉज ऑफ ए एक कांसेप्ट आया
प्रोसेस अब प्रोसेस क्या होता है मैंने
आपको बताया प्रोसेस में एप्लीकेशंस रन
होती है और उसको चार चीजों की
रिक्वायरमेंट होती है एक तो मेमोरी दूसरी
सिक्योरिटी थर्ड उसका थ्रेड्स और फोर्थ
आपका क्या है आईपीसी उसके बाद मैंने आपको
आईपीसी के बारे में बताया कि आईपीसी होती
क्या है और आप डेली बेसिस पर हर रोज
आईपीसी को यूज करते ही करते हो चलो आपको
एक चीज और दिखा देता हूं मैं बेसिक
स्ट्रक्चर आपको दिखा देता हूं आपके
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम की सो दैट आपको आईडिया हो
जाए उसके बाद सेशन को हम इतना ही करेंगे
आज उसके बाद फिर कंटिन्यू करेंगे नेक्स्ट
सेशन में थोड़ा सा प्रोसेस के बा बारे में
और इन सर्विसेस के बारे में थोड़ा सा और
डीप में जाएंगे कि एक्चुअल में ओके
प्रोसेस एक वर्चुलाइज कंटेनर तो है और
आईपीसी भी काफी हेल्प करती है काफी
इंपोर्टेंट है बट यह जो थ्रेड्स है जो
सिक्योरिटी है यह चीज यह सारी चीजें फिर
कैसे काम कर रही होती है आपके ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम क्योंकि आपको अपने ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
के बारे में जानना है अगर विंडोज ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम के बारे में सही से समझना है या
आपका ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम कैसे इनको रन करता
है यह समझने के लिए आपको हर एक चीज को
बारीकी से समझना होगा और मैं आपको ऐसी चीज
बताऊंगा कि आप बोलोगे सर ऐसा होता है हमें
तो पता नहीं था सच में ऐसा होता है मैं
आपको वो चीज उस पॉइंट पर सच में आप
सरप्राइज हो जाओगे कि सर ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
ऐसे काम करता है शायद आपको पता भी नहीं
होगा तो यह बेसिक इमेज आपके ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम की सबसे पहले आपका मदर बोर्ड होता
है मदर बोर्ड के ऊपर हार्डवेयर
एब्स्ट्रेक्शन लेयर होती है उसके बाद आपका
कर्नल आता है कर्नल ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम देन
उसके बाद ये आपकी विंडोज सर्विसेस जाती
हैं देन उसके बाद विज एप्लीकेशन आपका यूजर
स्पेस आता है दिस इज द बेसिक बिल्कुल
बेसिक टू बेसिक विंडोज ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
डायग्राम बता बिल्कुल हाई लेवल बिल्कुल
बेसिक है मतलब मदरबोर्ड हार्डवेयर
एब्स्ट्रेक्शन लेयर ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम कर्नल
विंडोज की सर्विसेस आती हैं उसके बाद
एप्लीकेशंस आती हैं वो आपका यूजर स्पेस
आता है सर्विसेस के बाद में यूजर स्पेस
आता है जन जैसे मैंने आपको बताया था
बूटिंग प्रोसेस में कि सेशन ़ देन उसके
बाद सेशन वन क्रिएट होता है तो यूजर स्पेस
में एंटर करते हो यूजर स्पेस की पहली
प्रोसेस थी मैं आपको बताया था ए एमएस डटी
एक् जो पहली प्रोसेस आपको बताई थ तो यहीं
से वो स्टार्ट होती है तो शायद आपको पता
होगा सेशन जीरो के बारे में नहीं तो
अपकमिंग क्लास में जब सर्विसेस पढ़ाऊंगा
तब भी आपको बता दूंगा तो यहां तक सबको
क्लियर है किसी को डाउट है तो मुझसे पूछ
सकता है चैट सेक्शन
में कर्नल हर्ट है कर्नल में मशीन लेवल
कर्नल क्या है कर्नल में सब कुछ जीरो वन
है सिग्नल्स ले रहा है जा रहा है यह है सब
वही है तो प्लीज आज के सेशन रिलेटेड किसी
का कोई डाउट है तो मुझसे पूछ सकता है और
फिर भी मुझे फिर भी आज यार आप लोग इस
स्ट्रेंथ देख के ना कि मुझे कई बार आप
लोगों प अब मुझे खुद प नहीं आप लोगों प
दया आ रही है आप लोगों को क्या होगा यार
और बताइए किसी का कोई सवाल है कोई डाउट है
मुझसे पूछ सकता है मुझे पता है कांसेप्ट
से रिलेटेड आपका कोई भी डाउट नहीं होगा
क्योंकि मैं जो कांसेप्ट पढ़ा रहा हूं
फंडामेंटल्स में आपको कभी भी कोई डाउट
नहीं आएगा क्योंकि मेरा जो पढ़ाने का
तरीका है और जिस तरीके से मैं आपके सामने
अप्रोच करता हूं और प्रेजेंट करता हूं
उसमें आपका डाउट होगा ही नहीं क्योंकि
आपके सारे डाउट सोच के मैं चीजों को वो
करता हूं अभी टास्क नहीं है कोई भी टास्क
के कंसेप्ट आएंगे आपको बता दिया
जाएगा व्हाट नेक्स्ट और नेक्स्ट टू
नेक्स्ट वीडियो विल बी ओके विनोद ठाकुर
चाहते कि अगले अगले वीडियो में बता देता
हूं उसके बाद विनोद ठाकुर ओके यह मुझे पता
यह मेरे काम का नहीं तो आई विल नॉट कम आई
विल नॉट टेल
यू नॉट पॉसिबल आप इसका प्रैक्टिस नहीं कर
स अरे आप फंडामेंटल्स का क्या प्रैक्टिस
करोगे
मतलब सोच के बोलिए थोड़ा कि आप किसकी
प्रैक्टिस करने के लिए बोल रहे हो मैं
आपको समझाने की कोशिश कर रहा हूं कि आपका
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम काम कैसे करता है और इसका
क्या प्रैक्टिकल करोगे कोई भी आपको ऐसी
लैब कौन देगा कि तुम इसके ऐसी प्रैक्टिस
कर पाओगे हां बत म जैसे जैसे आगे बढ़ेंगे
और यह प्रोसेसेस होती क्या है कैसे क्रिएट
होती है डीएलएल क्या होते हैं रजिस्ट्री
कैसे होती है कैसे आपका भी भी मेरा
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम अगर रन कर रहा तो कैसे कर
रहा होता मैं सारी चीज दिखाऊंगा करो साथ
के साथ डोंट
वरी तो विनोद ठाकुर अगर थ्योरी और
कांसेप्ट आपको नहीं समझना तो यार मैं आपको
फोर्स तो नहीं कर रहा क्योंकि अभी मैंने
फोर्स करना छोड़ दिया तो मुझे पता मेरे
फोर्स करने से कोई फायदा नहीं है
तो किसी कोई सवाल है या कोई कुछ भी पूछना
चाहता तो मुझसे पूछ सकता है अभी के लिए
अगर फिर भी आप बोल रहे हो सर सेशन को एंड
कर दीजिए तो हम एंड कर लेंगे क्योंकि मैं
थोड़े-थोड़े सेशन में इसलिए पढ़ा रहा हूं
ताकि आपके जो कांसेप्ट है वह क्लियर हो
जाए क्या चल रहा है क्या नहीं चल रहा वह
सारी चीजें आपकी क्लियर हो
जाए देखो डीसीएसपी में सारी चीजें
मैक्सिमम प्रैक्टिकल्स है आपकी सॉकेट
प्रोग्रामिंग यह चीजें होंगी अब वहां पर
इन सब चीजों के लिए ज्यादा टाइम वेस्ट
नहीं किया जाता हां जितना कुछ चीजें जो
इसमें नहीं पढ़ाए जाएंगे वो डीसी एसपी में
पढ़ाई जाती
है मैं आपको और भी डीप में
जाऊंगा
यस बिल्कुल मैं डीप में जाऊंगा एसवीसी
होस्ट
डई क्या है एक सर्विस है मैं आपको बता
देता हूं और एवीसी h एक एसीएम है कल मैंने
आपको बताया था सर्विस कंट्रोल मैनेजर है
जो सारी सर्विसेस को कंट्रोल करता है चार
टाइप के अकाउंट अकाउंट होते हैं वह चार
अकाउंट जो यही कंट्रोल करता है सेशन जीरो
में ऑपरेट करता
है दि आर द पार्ट ऑफ सर्विसेस आई विल
एक्सप्लेन विंडो विन इट डसी उसके बाद
एसवीसी होस्टड उससे पहले भी और भी है तो
एक सीक्वेंस में ही क्यों
है रीजन के साथ दिखाऊंगा दिखाऊं
बगा नेक्स्ट टॉपिक कंटिन्यू है थोड़ा हम
प्रोसेस के बारे में और डीप में जाएंगे
विंडोज ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम समझने के लिए हमें
प्रोसेस को समझना होगा कि प्रोसेस में
थोड़ा सा और डीप में जाएंगे जैसे मैंने
प्रोसेस प क्लिक किया तो क्या-क्या
हुआ क्या-क्या चीजें काम कर रही होती हैं
फॉर एग्जांपल अगर मैंने माइक्रोसॉफ्ट
विंडो पर भी क्लिक किया तो मेरे क्लिक
करने पर उसने क्या-क्या
किया ठीक है समझ रहे हो कि क्या क्या
सर्विसेस कौन सी या डीएलएल उठाई या आपकी
रजिस्ट्री उठाई तो रजिस्ट्री होता क्या है
डीएलएल होता क्या है सर्विसेस होता क्या
है यह सारी चीजें समझ पा रहे हो कि आपको
इशारा दे दिया
जीपीटी और एमबीआर तो आप सर्च कीजिए इतना
तो यार एमबीआर पहले यूज होता था और जीपीटी
अभी लेटेस्ट यूज होता
है या डेफिनेटली बहुत ज्यादा इंटरेस्टिंग
टॉपिक क्योंकि यह एक मैं आपको अगर बताऊं
कि फंडामेंटल क्यों डिलीवर कर रहा हूं ये
फंडामेंटल आपका इस तरीके का है जब मैं इन
फ्यूचर एक व शप लेके आऊंगा विंडोज की पलेज
की लेसन वहां पर ये कांसेप्ट आपको पता
होंगे ना तो आपके लिए बाए हाथ की चीजें
हैं ओके बोला ओके यह कांसेप्ट टच हुआ तो
मुझे डायरेक्टली चेक करना है बस चेक किया
अगर मिला तो ठीक है नहीं मिला तो नेक्स्ट
टाइम सेविंग फ्री में फंडामेंटल क्लियर
करो एडवांस में टेक्निकल टेक्निक सीखो
परफेक्ट है ना तो यही करना चाहिए
नहीं भाई मैं व एससीपी के लिए तैयारी भी
नहीं कर रहा हूं मेरे पास इतना टाइम है
नहीं लिटरली बोल रहा हूं मैं मैंने दिया
नहीं है बट मेरे पास इतना टाइम भी नहीं है
कि मैं उसके लिए तैयारी कर पाऊ क्योंकि
मेरे पास सच में बहुत टाइम नहीं मिलता
जितना टाइम मिलता तो आपके लिए से प्रिपेयर
करके डिलीवर कर पाता हूं अदर वाइज मैं
अपनी वर्किंग प्लेस प मुझे भी टाइम नहीं
मिलता अभी ये तो आप पता लगाइए कुंतालपुर
मैं कैसे याद रख सकता हूं आई एम ए
पेंटेस्टर मैं भी ग ही करके आपको
बताऊंगा बट हर जगह आईपीसी यूज करती यूज
होती है मैंने आपको बता
दिया विंडोज का बेसिक हां विंडोज पेन
टेस्टिंग मैं आपको सिखाऊंगा इसके बाद यही
तो है इसके बाद हम स्टार्ट करेंगे विंडोज
हम एक नेटवर्क से कनेक्टेड हैं वहां पर
जैसे हमने अभी लिनक्स से स्टार्ट किया था
जगतगुरु कि नक् में हमने क्या किया था कि
सीटीएफ लिया सीटीएफ को सॉल्व किया नक् प
प्लीज एस्केलेशन किया ऐसे ही बेसिक लेवल
पे इस पे भी करेंगे हम एडवांस लेवल पे फिर
मैं पेड वर्कशॉप में सिखाऊंगा
यह तो आप कुंटल कुंडू चैट जीपीटी बता देगा
आपको
एजेक्ट
निक क्या पूछ रहे हो आप मुझसे
निक चलो देखो जल्दी से पूछो फिर सेशन को
एंड करेंगे आप लोग भी फ्री हो जाओगे और
मैं भी फ्री हो
जाऊंगा जनली किसी का डाउट है तो पूछ पूछ
लीजिए
अयास न अपलोड करवाऊंगी थोड़े से हम दोनों
बिजी चल रहे हैं हम किसी प्रोजेक्ट में
बिजी है तो ट इज वई थोड़ा सा टाइम लग रहा
है यार मेरे बारे में मत जानने की कोशिश
किया करो
यार आई विल नॉट टेल यू एनी वन
बिकॉज नहीं बता
सकता एडवांस कोर्स टॉपिक
तो सरप्राइज है बट डेफिनेटली कि जो यह
पढ़ा रहे यह तो नहीं होगा थोड़ा सा
फंडामेंटल्स के कुछ हो सकता है बिल्कुल वन
टू पर वो हो सकता है बट बिल्कुल डिफरेंट
होता है एडवांस में रिपीट नहीं कि आपसे
फ्री में पढ़ा के उसके बाद उसमें वो कर
लिया
नो वेरी देखेंगे यार अभी सोचा नहीं है आप
लोगों इंटरेस्ट पर डिपेंड
करेगा इतना है कि मेरे प्राइस को हर कोई
एफर्ट कर पाता
है डोंट वरी जल्दी एड पन टेस्टिंग सीखो
पहले मेरे साथ ए पटेस्ट करो उसके बाद
एडवांस प जाओ ए पैन टेस्टिंग सीखनी है
नहीं
सीखनी ब्लैक हेट लेवल
की किसी भी एप्लीकेशंस को आप कैसे रिवर्स
इंजीनरिंग
करके और उसके कोड के साथ खेलने की कोशिश
कर सकते हो
मैंने पेन टेस्टिंग
यार मल्टीपल जगह से सीखा मैंने विद दी
हेल्प ऑफ ग विद दी हेल्प ऑफ
[संगीत]
तोके हम अभी एक काम करते हैं सेशन को एंड
करते हैं कुमार हम कोशिश
करेंगे अभी आई कांट गारंटी क्योंकि अभी
मुझे इस कोर्स को कंप्लीट करना
है आजकल कोडिंग सीखने की इतनी ज्यादा
जरूरत भी नहीं है चैट जीपीटी है ना आपके
लिए सब कुछ आसान कर देती है
[संगीत]
कभी नितेश सर बता देंगे
यार ओके तो सेशन को एंड करते हैं फिर अगर
कोई किसी का कोई सवाल नहीं है तो हम सेशन
को एंड करते हैं और फिर नेक्स्ट सेशन में
मिलेंगे कंटिन्यू करेंगे थोड़ा सा और डीप
जाएंगे
ओके फिर हम थोड़ा सा और डीप जाएंगे इस
कांसेप्ट में और ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम को बहुत
गहराई से समझेंगे तो बाय बाय एंड टेक केयर
एंड सी यू फॉर नेक्स्ट सेशन हमारे चैनल के
साथ बने रहिए रिवर्स इंजीनियरिंग तो पेड
में ही आएगा फ्री में नहीं आएगा तो हमारे
सेशन के साथ हमारे डिफरेंस अकेडमी के साथ
बने रहिए सब्सक्राइब कीजिए और ज्यादा से
ज्यादा लोगों को शेयर कीजिए और जवाइन करने
के लिए बोलिए जिनको सच में जरूरत है
लोगों को बचाइए पैसे वेस्ट करने से आप
लोगों जिम्मेदारी है अगर आप लोग सीख पा
रहे तो बाकी लोगों को भी बोलिए कि भाई
क्यों इतने पैसे वेस्ट करते हो इधर आके
सीखिए जो जिस बेसिक के लिए आप पैसे पे कर
रहे हो और वह बेसिक उधर मिल नहीं रहा है
यह सच बात
है ठीक है मैंने भी बहुत जगह पैसे वेस्ट
किए हुए तो इसलिए मुझे त तजुर्बा है कि
कहां पर क्या प्रॉब्लम है कहां पर कितनी
प्रॉब्लम है तो मैंने भी सारी चीजों के
एक्सपीरियंस है ट्स व्हाई आई एम टीचिंग यू
कि यह चीजें इस तरीके से डिलीवर होनी
चाहिए इस तरीके से लोगों को समझाने चाहिए
सो दैट की एक्सपर्ट है जिनको पता है व सब
कहीं से भी सीख लेंगे जिनको कुछ नहीं पता
वह कहां से
सीखेंगे
ओके नेक्स्ट
मैं आपको बता दूंगा मे बी डे आफ्टर टुमारो
आई विल
प्लानिंग ओके तो ओके बाय बाय एंड टुमारो
सी यू फॉर नेक्स्ट सेशन गुड नाइट